if you think living to a hundred is
impressive think again here's a glimpse
at some of the longest living life-forms
on earth the average human lives for 71
years but the oldest on official record
the gene Louise comment survived to see
her 120 second birthday humans don't
even come close to the Galapagos giant
tortoise one of the oldest on record
named Jonathan is still going strong at
184 years old believed to have hatched
around 1930 - Jonathan - tortoise was
around when Andrew Jackson was still
President of the United States but
tortoise Jonathan's impressive run is
nothing compared to what we find under
the sea swimming in the frigid Arctic
waters is the longest living mammal on
earth the bowhead whale which can
survive for over 200 years
next is the oldest vertebrate on record
a Greenland shark estimated to be around
400 years old this shark was alive
around the same time Italian astronomer
Galileo Galilei was launching a
scientific revolution
turning now to invertebrates we have the
edible clam the ocean Quahog the oldest
ocean Quahog clam was found to be five
hundred seven years old around five
hundred years ago Michelangelo finished
the Sistine Chapel and for even more
perspective Christopher Columbus reached
the America not long before that think
about that the next time you eat one now
we get into the life-forms that have
been around since the dawn of human time
first up are the Bristlecone Pines which
have been found to live for over 5,000
years
then there's the Kings La Masia an
individual tree will only live for about
300 years but this tasmanian shrub
conclude itself creating younger
versions of itself estimates suggest
that has been living consecutively for
over 43,000 years in the Mediterranean a
species of zebras also known as Neptune
grass is believed to be two hundred
thousand years old fossil records
suggest that's when the first modern
humans or Homo sapiens started to roam
the earth now some bacteria are also
living forms they are the true winners
bacteria found frozen underground in
Siberia are estimated to be about
500,000 years old shockingly its DNA was
intact and the bacteria were still alive
infected so it looks like the gift of
exceptional long life requires you to be
spineless and microscopic a fair trade
we'll let you decide